the series is set in the year 2149 when
the Earth's ability to support life is
reaching its end as oxygen is depleting
day by day due to over development
people are having difficulties breathing
so they are forced to wear specialized
masks moreover the world has become so
polluted that the plants can no longer
grow and fruits are considered rare to
keep things strictly under control a
military-like law enforcement system has
been imposed they have adopted a
two-child policy to combat the
overpopulation issue on the other hand
the scientists have also achieved a
breakthrough they have discovered a tear
in the fabric of space-time which leads
them to Terra Nova the prehistoric Earth
of 85 million years ago in other words
the scientists have found a time portal
that can teleport them to the Cretaceous
Period where the world is still green
and dinosaurs are still active
[Music]
foreign
at the start of the series Jim Shannon a
cop by profession enters his residence
wearing a rebreather which is an oxygen
mask to support airflow Jim lives with
his wife Elizabeth a medical officer and
three children Josh Maddie and Zoe in
this way despite being a cop himself he
has violated the two-child policy soon
he takes out an orange from his bag and
the entire family is very surprised
since fruit and vegetables are in short
supply as the family is having a good
time with the orange what does that mean
Maddie suddenly enters the apartment and
warns them that she saw the population
control police in the lobby this alarmed
the parents and they quickly hide little
Zoe in an air vent shortly after the
police come in and start rummaging
through the place it appears as if
someone informed them about the third
child at least if they find her her
final memory will be going nuts with
that orange they search everywhere but
fail to find the little girl however
just as they're about to leave a scared
Zoe whimpers from the vent and gets
discovered devastated Jim begs the cops
to release his daughter and even starts
fighting them however he is easily
outnumbered and taken into custody
himself for his offense he's handed over
an eight-year sentence two years later
Elizabeth tips off a prison guard and
finally manages to visit her husband Jim
is sick in his cell due to poor air
quality and the lack of a rebreather as
the two reconcile Elizabeth reveals that
she has been given a position as a
medical officer in the 10th pilgrimage
but she is not allowed to take Zoe the
10th pilgrimage is the tenth group of
human colonists who will be allowed to
travel to Terra Nova where they can
start a new life before leaving she
tells Jim that he is their last hope and
sneaks in a rebreather after a while Jim
checks the rebreather and finds a hidden
laser knife inside hot damn in the next
scene Elizabeth Maddie and Josh check in
go through security and head towards the
time portal on the other hand Jim
manages to get out of the prison with
the help of the laser knife and arrives
at the check-in area he slides into a
restricted room where he pays a large
amount of money in exchange for a
certain bag unfortunately the officers
notice him on camera breaching the
restricted area by this time Elizabeth
and the children have already walked in
through the portal but when Jim tries to
follow them an officer stops him since
the time portal is irreversible anyone
who reaches Terra Nova cannot return Jim
knows about this so he elbows the
officer steals his gun and runs into the
portal to follow his family as soon as
he enters the portal he reaches the
prehistoric Earth which is completely
different from the world they just
laughed Jim finally reunites with his
family but when a soldier notices the
weapon in his hand he is held at
gunpoint the soldier then checks the
suspicious bag that Jim is carrying
unsurprisingly little Zoe comes out of
it seeing the entire family together the
soldiers leave them be what you're doing
is all kinds of illegal but God damn it
you made it to Dinosaur World so have a
good day later as the group proceeds
towards Terra Nova little Zoe comments
on the sky she notes that she had never
seen the clouds so wide and the trees so
green after entering Terra Nova for the
first time The Travelers of the 10th
pilgrimage are greeted by Commander
Nathaniel Taylor one of the first people
to enter the travel portal he gives a
short introduction of the place and
assures that everyone is going to have a
better life from today onwards so long
as they don't get their asses ripped off
by dinosaurs following this he confronts
Jim and Elizabeth and berates them for
breaking the law however when the couple
pleads for a fresh start he lets them
keep their three children Jim wants to
stay a cop in Terra Nova as well but
given his history Taylor assigns him to
the agricultural Department next the
family settles into their new home
Maddie and Zoe fight for their new rooms
while their parents contemplate if they
made the right decision by coming to
Terra Nova as everyone is busy moving
their belongings they notice that Zoe
has wandered off outside a curious Zoe
approaches a brachiosaur a dinosaur
species and feeds it with some Fern
surprisingly the giant herbivore accepts
it which makes the little girl very
happy the following day Josh and Maddie
head towards an orientation meeting
where they meet a fellow resident Sky
enter friends Tasha Max and Hunter after
the introductions Josh decides to
explore Terra Nova with Skye while
Maddie prefers to learn about their new
home by attending the orientation
meeting shortly after Skye and her
friends take Josh into the jungle they
arrive at a beautiful waterfall and jump
into it near the waterfall Sky shows
Josh some rocks wear golden colored
symbols are carved into them since
Taylor has forbidden anyone to visit
this area Sky makes Josh promise to keep
the stones a secret elsewhere in the
medical sector Elizabeth attends to a
patient surrounded by officers she
wonders why the patient needs security
and one of the officers informs her that
he is a Sixers member Sixers appear to
be a group of rebels who have separated
themselves from Terra Nova their main
goal is to overthrow Commander Taylor
and Rob the main colony of all its
resources suddenly the patient jumps
from his bed and threatens to kill
Elizabeth with a laser knife after using
her as a hostage and forcing the
officers to disarm the man flees outside
Jim notices the man acting suspicious
and follows him soon enough the man
attempts to attack Taylor but Jim
successfully stops him Jim knows that
there is more than a mere Paradise in
Terra Nova so he demands Taylor explain
about the man and why he was trying to
kill him however with everyone around
the latter insists Jim get in his
vehicle for a ride after the two reach
the same waterfall from before Taylor
starts explaining about the Sixers he
reveals that the Sixers came from the
sixth pilgrimage with a secret supply of
weapons however he doesn't know why the
group wants to overthrow him Taylor then
commends Jim on his bravery and offers
him to join Terra Nova's Security Forces
as the two continue chatting they notice
a group of Sixers heading toward their
colony wasting no time they begin
pursuing the Sixers But realize that
they are actually fleeing from two
Carnotaurus a species of carnivorous
dinosaurs Taylor and his group somehow
managed to repel the dinosaurs but they
still have to deal with their Arch
enemies Mira the leader of the Sixers
comes out of her vehicle along with the
others and starts talking she reveals
that she is there to negotiate the
release of Carter the same guy who tried
to kill Taylor earlier she then brings
forth a large box of meteoric iron an
extremely rare element and proposes to
trade it for Carter realizing that the
element is too valuable to give up on
Taylor agrees to the terms and releases
Carter elsewhere in the jungle Josh sky
and the other friends start making booze
from Wild fruits while they are enjoying
themselves they hear a loud roar Sky
explains it's an axoraptor otherwise
known as the slasher it is a dinosaur
species with colorful feathers and a
whip-like bladed tail capable of cutting
a man in half but she assures Josh not
to fear as slashers mostly hunt at night
mostly suddenly they hear an even louder
howl so they decide to return to their
vehicle however they are seen spotted by
a couple of deadly slashers the group
somehow manages to take refuge in an
armored vehicle abandoned by the Sixers
but by this time several slashers have
surrounded them in the attack Tasha Max
and Hunter get seriously injured back in
the colony Terra Nova security finds
footage of the teenagers sneaking away
fearing the worst Jim Elizabeth and some
soldiers head to the forest to rescue
the children fortunately they find the
group in the neck of time and scare away
the dinosaurs using some Advanced
Machinery following the close call they
head back to Terra Nova later Sky visits
Taylor and his residence and apologizes
for initiating the trip during their
conversation we realized that sky is an
orphan whose dads served under Taylor
both of her parents were taken away by
fever some years back imagine living
with dinosaurs and getting killed by a
fever one day a group of Terra Nova
soldiers goes out into the woods to get
some supplies however they are attacked
and brutally killed by some unseen
creatures in the meantime Josh Maddie
and Zoe attend a survival seminar taught
by Lieutenant Alicia Washington the
second in command to Taylor Maddie is a
smart kid and she eagerly answers most
of the questions asked by the lieutenant
later that night when Jim and Elizabeth
start getting intimate a creature starts
screaming so Jim goes outside to inspect
it is the same unseen animal that
attacked the soldiers earlier but Jim
doesn't know this so he simply scares it
away the following day Taylor and Jim
plan to search for the missing man
thinking it was the Sixers that attacked
them meanwhile Elizabeth is working in
the medical sector when she bumps into
Malcolm Wallace one of her good friends
from college Malcolm tells her that he
is a science officer there that sounds
made up Malcolm just then Jim walks in
and interrupts their conversation
Elizabeth quickly introduces the two to
each other but when Malcolm learns that
Jim is her husband he is taken aback in
the next scene Jim along with Taylor and
the crew head out to the woods while
driving Taylor asks Jim to investigate
who is giving Mira information about
Terra Nova he believes that there's a
mole within the colony the group then
arrives at the murder spot when they see
the dead soldiers they notice that their
faces have been disfigured after a bit
of checking around they bring the dead
bodies back to Terra Nova and the
medical team led by Elizabeth and
Malcolm starts examining them Elizabeth
deduces that the soldiers were attacked
from above just then Jim who is also in
the lab notices a claw-like piece on one
of the corpses with this clue the
medical officers decide to stay late to
find out what creature could have killed
the man however even after hours of
research they don't find any specimen
that matches the mysterious claw when
Elizabeth returns home Jim asks her
about Malcolm after he presses the issue
she finally tells him that she dated
Malcolm for a while before breaking it
off herself probably after learning that
there's no such thing as a science
officer later that night the couple
attempts intimacy once again but to
their bad luck they are again
interrupted by the same creature this
thing is dangerous and a pervert this
time Josh joins his father outside and
they notice several of the same
creatures there Josh tries scaring them
away with a rock but only ends up making
them angry they swarm over the
father-son duo like a deadly rash but
before any Serious injury is caused Josh
and Jim make it inside the house the
next day Malcolm examines Jim's injuries
from the creatures and realizes that
they're the same ones that killed the
man after treating the injuries a
curious gem asks Taylor about Malcolm
and learns that he was the one who
requested Elizabeth's Survival on Terra
Nova outside Skye and Josh are roaming
around the market when they notice a
large flock of the same Birds but before
they could warn the others the birds
start attacking everyone they leave the
place after a few minutes but by this
time several residents are seriously
injured meanwhile Malcolm recovers one
of the dead birds and concludes that
they are an unknown type of pterosaur a
species of flying reptile in a meeting
with Taylor and his crew Malcolm deduces
that the pterosaurs may be migrating
Taylor reveals that years ago he and
Lieutenant Alicia had discovered
thousands of eggshells while digging the
ground on which Terra Nova sits today
but since they were already hatched the
officers thought the creatures had long
since moved on Additionally the shells
made the ground so fertile that they
decided to make the settlement in this
location hearing this Malcolm concludes
that the pterosaurs are attacking them
because Terra Nova sits upon their
breeding rounds since the medical
officers do not know much about the new
species Malcolm and Elizabeth tell
Taylor that they will need a live male
and female specimen of the pterosaurs to
try to come up with a solution to defend
against them next Jim prepares to head
out of the colony to get the specimens
while Malcolm details him about the
species however instead of listening Jim
confronts him for still being in love
with his wife as he was the one who
requested her presence in Terra Nova
this shocks Malcolm and he defends
himself by saying that he called
Elizabeth as she is the best medical
officer he has ever known a while later
Jim returns with the two sad specimens
after studying the creatures Malcolm and
Elizabeth discover that they can produce
an extremely powerful pheromone that
could be used to lure all of the
pterosaurs away from the colony and to
another location where they can breed as
more pterosaurs continue to arrive at
the settlement Taylor orders the
security team members to be stationed
All Around The Colony Mark Reynolds a
young soldier who evidently has a crush
on Maddie comes to her home for security
on the other hand also brings Sky to
keep her safe from the creatures soon
after a giant swarm of pterosaurs
invades the settlement and starts
wreaking havoc a few of them forced
their way into Jim's house via the air
duct Mark being a soldier tries to scare
them away but only ends up getting his
ass knocked out despite this Josh and
the group fight valiantly and hold off
the creatures long enough to lock
themselves in another room elsewhere at
the medical lab Elizabeth and Malcolm
finally finished preparing the
pheromones now all they have to do is
lure the pterosaurs away the commander
Taylor decides to volunteer and Jim also
joins him soon the two gear up and leave
in a vehicle which starts spraying the
pheromone surprisingly the plan works
and despite Taylor and Jim receiving
some minor Cuts they managed to lure the
entire swarm of pterosaurs away from
Terra Nova the episode ends as all the
residents come out of their homes and
resume their normal lives again to know
what happens to them next watch the
second part in our new channel series
recapped